[Musique]
il est important que le milieu maritime
soit je dirais examiné parce que la
france possède le deuxième espace
maritime le plus étendu au monde donc
qu'il convient que l'on puisse réfléchir
sur son avenir
on parle beaucoup des intérêts
économiques stratégiques mais on connaît
peu finalement ces grands fonds marins
on connaît peu cette colonne d'eau on
dit que 3 ou 4% simplement de la
biodiversité est aujourd'hui appréhender
et donc il est important aussi au
travers de cette quête cette recherche
qui est engagée par la france
d'améliorer la connaissance d'abord pour
la connaissance fondamentale mais aussi
pourquoi pas demain pour tout ce qui
concerne le médical ou d'autres
applications qu'on ne connaît pas
aujourd'hui les minerais et la recherche
des minerais notamment de ses fameuses
terra procède de la volonté de maîtriser
un certain nombre de ressources qui sont
aujourd'hui sur planté reste maîtrisée
par la chine est donc tout l'enjeu
consiste à ce que la france maîtrise
également ses ressources parce que c'est
ce que nous avons dans les batteries nos
téléphones portables c'est ce que nous
avons en matière lunetterie donc il ya
des applications dans la vie de tous les
jours en fait sont plus possibles si
nous n'avons pas accès à un certain
nombre de ressources je crois savoir
aussi que nos tests pcr tire partie
aussi de découverte de cette de ce grand
océan qu'on connaît peu et c'est ce qui
nous permet aujourd'hui de détecter si
nous sommes positifs ou pas là qu'ovide
donc voilà des explications au concret
des applications concrètes mais je crois
qu'on ne connaît pas
on va dire une grande partie de ceux
dont on pourra tirer profit demain des
océans la france est riche de sa
diversité marine c'est justement ce qui
fait l'intérêt de la france le fait que
nous ayons un littoral qui soit
différent suivant les territoires où
l'on se trouve on a parfois l'impression
que on veut regarder les choses par race
albou or l'océan c'est un tout et il
convient de l'analyse et de manière
globale et c'est le sens de cette vision
c'est un enjeu site protection de
protection de ses ressources nouvelles
donc protection de cette biodiversité
mais protection de ce qu'on ne connaît
pas encore il faut protéger
prévoir pour les générations futures et
c'est aussi l'enjeu de cette mission
d'information